leonidas is the king
and he has his queen
when
when someone comes to his doorstep and
threatens him literally threatens his
his whole livelihood his people
with literally cutting people's heads
off walking up to him and showing
violence
his queen stepped up and said
this is not okay
and the messenger was turning around and
saying how dare you as a woman
speak
and in the end when leonidas then
before he kicked them down the well
um he actually said you disrespected my
queen and actually what she said as well
is she said like only spartan women can
give birth to spartan men which is
strong men so what is beautiful about
that relationship is that they are not
equal in the sense that they don't have
the same energy
but we can agree that they're both
strong in different ways that's not a
partnership because he needs okay so
what what i meant is i'm not saying
she's eating she needs him more than he
needs her so what i'm saying is i'm not
saying that they're equal and that they
give the same thing in but what they do
is that they complement each other and
support each other and the beautiful
thing about that relationship is that
she's actually very accomplished so he
feels safe walking away and going into
war potentially never coming back but he
knows that his wife is strong so she can
go and she will use her way of doing
things to try and help the country can i
just say something is so is it is the
definition of a partnership 50 50 right
you're right
so i think that's the biggest problem
for men when we hear partnership because
we think
when we hear 50 50 we think hold on so
if we go if we gotta get into a fight
now it's not 50 50. because if someone
comes to roblox down the street right
now it's not 50 50. i gotta deal with
100 of the i got a deal with him so when
we hear partnership we think that's cool
because there's certain places where we
want women to be feminine so if we're a
family gathering
you might be more vocal than us that's
fine because we don't want to talk so
there's it's like a partnership doesn't
have to be
50 50 in my opinion you can have you can
have a solid relationship without having
to be 50 50 all the way we can you can
be better women can be better some
things than men as i you're more
maternal than us you can do with
children better than us we're fine with
the problem with women nowadays in my
opinion we're trying to make everything
so equal and it's like it's just not
like that it's not enough it's not it's
not in our biological it's not innate at
all yeah and i agree with you with that
as well because i i i guess i have the
my definition of partnerships a bit
different from you so when i'm saying a
partnership i didn't mean it has to be
100 50 50 in every single aspect right
but you're changing the definition of a
word okay so it's like that's sorry no i
i i i do apologize i'm not trying to i'm
not offended i'm just i'm just saying
like that's not what it means um
question for you what have you seen in
divorce court do you feel like men and
women demonize each other the same
what's your experience with that uh
no i think women are more ready to just
demonize the husband like if they're
going in the arena of divorce like okay
this is happening they're ready to just
cut him out as much you know whatever
way possible
and i've seen
very commonly like okay what's going on
who is this you know where does this
come from and then he just has to it's
sad so first initial reaction is he's
sad he's like okay this is this is where
it's going and then he has to just now
defend himself all this accusation so
yeah and then he might be disgusted and
then he's just retaliating but she's the
one that always starts it i'm glad you
said that i've seen
just saying how it is
so i'm curious um have you had i i know
the majority of divorces are initiated
by women have you had men initiate
divorce yeah sometimes what are the
typical reasons that men initiate from
what you've seen so what i've seen so
sometimes it's
adultery
or she gets
to
like she's trying to take charge in the
house
and start demanding things so she's she
doesn't have to like she if she's if she
especially if she's educated so she's
got got a job
and she's coming home late
and then she can't she's too tired to as
a percentage is just roughly off your
experience of men initiate divorce and
initiate divorce
the percentage well i don't know
because i know what
i know the percentage of that poll has
got statistics but what have you seen in
your own experience men initiate too yes
like roughly the last time we saw is
around like 15 percent
really
yeah that means a statistic
that's how bad it is yeah but again the
english courts i have to say we it's not
like straight away it's not as bad as
california i'm going to say for for
example how how long do you think women
want to leave marriages before they do
how long yeah typically so from as soon
as they get married and
yeah like like um they they just always
say like if a girl starts working out
and going to the gym she's leaving your
ass
i don't know i mean that's really
relative i don't mean maybe
i would say
like six months six months
to a few years
it sounds really extreme but if it keeps
happening there's all these patterns
yeah okay
um so what about you guys
do you guys have ex-girlfriends no never
never had an ex really yeah no i got a
girl now i've never had it how long have
you been with her
well we was together ten years and we
split up for three years then we got
back together okay yeah
all right oh that's pretty cute yeah
um does she demonize you oh yeah 100 she
does yeah
um
i'm not going to get into the details
because i'm not here to be emotional or
anything like that but it was a
it was quite uh
let's just say abusive simply um
and she loved to demonize me for it and
you know i had the
the mindset back then i still do you
know like if she's dressing
as we'd say like a slug
then i wouldn't have it and i'm like and
i said to her like if you want to dress
like that that's fine but don't like
don't be with me you know you still got
your choice i'm not controlling choice
but she'd take that and make me into
being controlling
but
like
i don't know she turned me into the the
demon and then um
i think what she's doing is gather
lighting
so
which sadly happens both ways because i
personally have only have one x and he
did exactly that to me for a good two
years
and it's
it's it's it's been literally a
life-changing experience and i think
what's really sad is that this is
literally like it doesn't matter what
gender there are good people out there
who just you know we were simple-minded
people who just wanted to we were
excited to meet someone who we thought
we were going to be happy with and these
people are they're so good at
manipulating you they love bomb you they
say you oh my god i love you i want to
have your kids what like you just fall
for them and when they have their
clothes in you
boom if they start coming in and you're
like okay girls i think girls like toxic
men
i agree i agree yeah
i think like there's something you're
attracted to about it
do you know why
um well i think it's because like the
same traits the hero has the villain has
too so if a dude is very like they
always say like why why does that girl
stay with their girlfriend or the
why does the girl stay with the
boyfriend that beats her up well it's
because like that aggression that's in
the hero is also in the villain you ask
any girl if when they say like
they got a crush a celebrity crush or
something i guarantee it's gonna be the
villain in the movie
they like the bad guys it's just
would it be okay if i just just make the
distinction and the reason why these
girls are getting it wrong
yes they
women actually go look in a romance
novel
men like they're corn girls like the
books we look very differently and you
can go to romans now one in a bookstore
you can see that girls tend to go for
the hunky guys the the vampires the bad
boys and they changed them right it's
all about changing them now
now now the imp